it's like we don't care about the Merit
we care about the wedding and you'll
you'll see stories of like previous
generations like one two three
generations ago where they they knew
each other for three months and they got
married but it's like we keep raising
the price for men on commitment you know
guy guys used to date a chick for three
months and get married
can you imagine a man doing that
nowadays like can you can you imagine
that that sounds unheard of so ow it's
like okay he's got the risk of losing
half his stuff all right he's got the
risk of losing his children he's got the
risk of getting falsely accused of a
crime he's got the risk of
finding out later that his wife has
slept with a million people and
now he has the cost of spending in some
states up to a hundred thousand dollars